[Musique]
action
[Applaudissements]
attendez les gars que j'arrête de baiser
ce qui me paraît quand même content mon
improbable tant qu en ce moment je suis
sur une course de bèze ascendante
qu'est ce que tu fais il aurait pu tout
mythe bien plus pire ding dong hwa genre
comme sa compagne c'était bien
[Rires]
moi j'ai un produit six adultes a pas
pensé à ma mère un petit truc par là non
[Musique]
va te faire pénétrer
j'aime faire pénétrer toujours mieux
qu'avec ton magicien mais mon magicien
mais il est magique
monsieur wade a une grosse bague est
parti
[Applaudissements]
non pas qu'un qu'il apprend que sincère
c'est pas deux
vous vivez toujours en somme beaucoup de
couples divorcés et vivre sous le même
toit
ces monnaies courantes je possède 20% de
cette même tu m'achètes 9 1% où je vais
inviter dans mes jambes pour cent mais
papa m'a vraiment revenir ici pouvait
pas divorcer comme tout le monde non vie
au direct tu vois bien que oui voilà
vous avez des problèmes conjugaux
on sait bien que tout à fait récente
réunion de quoi pas de virer ma photo
non non je trouve ça génial tu verrais
aucun inconvénient à laisser ta chambre
à ton père quoi ouais tu peux venir voir
tu viens voir tout de suite tout ce
qu'elle a dit touché par ça c'est à
partie 20% de la maison 20% du frigo
je crois que c'est sain pour moi de te
voir te trimballes est à poil par poil
au japon à briques t'as pas un euro pour
la 20e ex que j'aime bien mon
portefeuille
on laisse tomber j'ai piqué disons à
maman tu voulais rendre à quand tu
pourras manger moins sage mais c'est
quand même pas n'importe quelle vie de
merde parce qu'après ben moi je regarde
et puis ça me rend le mot tous et pierre
mehn des mecs à la maison pour faire des
plans à trois c'est lui mon amour votre
mais c'est une grosse info juillet l'ema
non pas tu restes ici
pour tous les deux un instant mais
allez-y les enfants on a besoin de
parler entre adultes c'est à vous que je
m'adresse à toi merci